[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau à tanis
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui benoît
peeters critique historien et auteur de
bandes dessinées qui publie trois
minutes pour comprendre 50 moments clés
de l'histoire de la bande dessinée ou
courrier du livre ça va de l'invention
de la bande dessinée par rodolphe
toffler il ya deux siècles au roman
graphique aujourd'hui en passant par
hergé stade leavitt hugo pratt j'avais
10 ans victor hugo élément gas on va
revivre ensemble toutes ces petites
révolutions benoît peeters mais
commençons par notre époque voici
l'image que vous avez choisi pour la
symboliser c'est la couverture de mars
le célèbre livre de dart spiegelman
alors le livre qui a lancé le roman
graphique le livre qui a fait découvrir
la qualité de la bande dessinée à
beaucoup de gens certains ont même dit
c'est plus une bande dessinée c'est la
seule bande dessinée qui a eu le prix
pulitzer autrefois or elle est
aujourd'hui au coeur d'un micro scandale
mais révélateur puisque dans le
tennessee
des écoles ont voté à l'unanimité pour
faire retirer ce livre des bibliothèques
à cause de quelques gros mots à cause
d'une images de nudité c'est celle
minuscule du suicide de la mère de
l'auteur dans une baignoire et aussi
parce qu'il n'était pas bon de de
transmettre aux enfants des informations
aussi négative aussi noir bon voilà donc
cette bande dessinée qui transpose sous
forme animalière la shoah qui est un
manuel d'histoire extraordinaire qui en
même temps le début de la bande dessinée
autobiographique et là tout d'un coup on
décide comme ça de l'éliminer donc ça
vient évidemment du petit petit coin
dans le dans le tennessee mais je crois
que ce symptôme a quand même frappé
parce que tout d'un coup on a
l'impression que c'est aussi entendement
dessinée que ce livre est interdit parce
qu'on voit des choses pour pourtant par
rapport à tant de films qui ont essayé
de relancer l'irreprésentable on peut
dire que le dessin c'est déjà une
manière de de créer une distance de
rendre les choses moins insupportable
mais voilà ça n'a pas ça n'a pas suffi
c'est un événement local heureusement
assez mal ensemble des états unis mais
mais ça nous dit que la bande dessinée
continue à susciter parfois des
réactions un peu folle quand un peu
absurde à une époque mais on on accusait
les super héros de favoriser josée maure
les perversions des enfants via le
pousse au crime il ya toutes les lois
sur la protection de la jeunesse en
france conduit louisville a pas mal
d'années pour qu'on reconnaisse que la
bande dessinée pouvait s'adresser non
seulement aux enfants qui sont
d'ailleurs capable de voir et d'entendre
et de lire des choses intéressantes mais
mais aussi à des publics adolescents ou
adultes et bien commençons benoît
peeters on va ouvrir à présent votre
livre le premier des 50 moment de
l'histoire de la bande dessinée que vous
répertoriés c'est son invention en 1827
par rodolphe toffler un suisse qui
dessine des histoires en images la
première à être publiés en 1833 genève
s'intitule l'histoire de monsieur jabot
on la regarde elle est là s'il n'y a pas
de doute c'est bien une bande dessinée
oui alors de faire est un personnage
extraordinaire d'abord parce qu'il était
fils de peintre au début il rêvait
d'être peintre et puis là une maladie
des yeux il se dit j'ai pas une vue
assez précises pour devenir peintre mais
je sais écrire je sait dessiner je vais
essayer de faire quelque chose avec les
deux donc c'est du service ont un
handicap qui crée la naissance de la
bande et puis ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est qu'il a tout de suite conscience
que c'est bien autre chose que du texte
plus des images que ce une forme 9 ici
on voit de la musique qui à l'arrêt des
notes de musique des futures bulles on
voit un rêve est complètement incroyable
c'est à dire une image dans l'image et
puis surtout il ya chez thfr la
confiance dans ce nouveau mode
d'expression ce qui se dit çà va parler
à tout le monde ça peut parler à tout le
monde et le genre va être riche d'avenir
il donnera lieu à des poèmes des essais
des histoires il est à la fois le
premier premier auteur l'inventeur mais
aussi le théoricien le premier
théoricien avec une fois une confiance
ailleurs chose étonnante aussi te faire
à créer des livres des petits livres
horizontaux qui faisait imprimer lui
même et donc on croit souvent de la
bande dessinée balle est né dans les
journaux elle va passer ensuite dans les
journaux mais d'abord ce sont des petits
livres ils appellent ça de la
littérature en estampe on n'est pas bien
loin du roman graphique et savez vous
qui est le premier critiques de bande
dessinée après hier personne qui a écrit
sur top faire non ces gouttes le monde
explique marc guillou qui
s'enthousiasment pour cette nouvelle
forme de comics pour cette manière dont
les personnages réapparaît d'image en
image et donc une bonne leçon pour ceux
qui en font mine d'être trop cultivé
pour s'intéresser à la bande dessinée
voilà on a notre premier critiques de
bande dessinée qui n'est autre que un
des plus grands écrivains et aux langues
allemand alors le deuxième moment clé
pour vous c'est cham chams est en france
un chat avec son histoire de la russie
en 1854 ça c'est pas ça la jav a
présenté aussi des bd mais la sécu staff
doré oui le grand gustave doré tout
jeune
qui va après pas s'illustrer commencé
dans la gravure l'illustration des
grands mais qui raconte l'histoire de la
sainte russie sur un mode assez passé
polimique d'ailleurs mais qu' énormément
d'invention graphique c'est un tout
jeune homme est mort ce qui est
fascinant c'est de voir que juste après
toepfer cham nadar futurs grands
photographes doré s'enthousiasme pour
cette forme ce à quoi on pourrait croire
que te plaire a été isolé en fait les
livres sont arrivés très vite à paris en
édition pirate d'abord c'est amusant ils
ont été imités et donc ils ont créé une
émulation et plein d'auteurs tout au
long du xixème siècle vont pratiquer la
bd alors qu'on a longtemps cru
mythologiquement que la bd était né
presque au moment du cinéma et aux états
unis en servant les aspirants du cinéma
d'ailleurs voilà et on s'aperçoit
qu'elle est née à peu près en même temps
que le daguerréotype que la photo les
berges hante et en suisse et en france
alors regardons benjamin rabier je
trouve ça la journée d'une paire de
jambes en et en 1908 dans la jeunesse
illustré et ça je trouve alors c'est
extrêmement rare l'astra ordinaire
c'était il ya des pages de rabieh acquis
connu comme un grand illustrateur de
livres enfants mais qui est méconnu
comme auteur de bandes dessinées et là
on s'aperçoit que ça on a vraiment un
jeu avec le langage de la bande dessinée
un humour tout à fait spécifique 7 c'est
quelque chose qui aurait pu naître il ya
quelques quelques années et donc c'est
un plaisir en parcourant
aujourd'hui par les les fonds numérisés
par la bibliothèque de france sur
gallica de voir ressurgir toute une
matière qui était dans les journaux
qu'on avait oublié que les historiens et
moi le premier pendant longtemps ont
méconnu on s'appuie en fait sur deux
grands repères qu'ils étaient des livres
pour en parler de bécassine on parlait
de la famille fenouillard mais on
parlait pas de cépages qui était parue
dans la presse parce que simplement
c'était des journaux fragile et
d'accessible on vous découvre
aujourd'hui que la bande dessinée a été
vivante on dans toute l'europe à travers
tout le 19e siècle avant de connaître
une immense popularité évidemment dans
le monde nord-américain alors vous avez
cité la famille fenouillard du
dessinateur christophe c'est à partir de
la fin 1889 la famille fenouillard et ça
ça va avoir un très grand succès
populaire à très très grand succès et ce
qui est tout à fait remarquable avec
christophe sait que c'est un des auteurs
qui va parler à plusieurs générations et
donc ça sera transmis des parents aux
enfants et puis les livres la famille
fenouillard le sapeur camembert et bien
d'autres vont passer vraiment le temps
puisque ça c'est un support rigide et on
trouve jusque dans les années 50 et 60
dans les bibliothèques des familles dans
les greniers beaucoup beaucoup des
livres de christopher christophe ça
c'est étonnant parce que c'est un humour
qui est d'abord verbale c'est très drôle
concentré il écrit avant de décider ce
mois là c'est un peu plus sage sûr sur
le plan visuel des images sont assez
séparer la manche est offert en avait
réellement des images qu'ils se
joignaient une action qui était presque
possible lire sans le texte chez
christophe c'est pas du tout le cas mais
s'est plaint de ses pleins de qualités
plein d'invention d'un humour qui a qui
a bien tenu à la famille fenouillard
serait formidable ils vont à l'expo
universelle ils font bêtise sur bêtise
il loupe leurs trains ils sont toujours
à côté ils sont jamais à l'endroit est
ce qu'il faut ce qui est fou c'est qu'on
connaît encore le bois jamais oui je
sais qu'il ya une famille fenouillard
voilà à des mises et cunégonde sans les
lélés les deux filles voient l'annoncé
c'est vraiment une belle série et
christophe était en fait c'est un
pseudonyme georges colomb georges colomb
donc le pseudonyme est déjà un jeu et
c'était un professeur très sérieux et il
a fait une leçon de choses en bande
dessinée donc là aussi pour ceux qui
méprisent ou sous-estiment la bande
dessinée on voit un monsieur très très
sérieux quitte à la fin de sa vie s'est
beaucoup battu sur le véritable lieu de
la bataille d'alésia et fait des
recherches et des redites là dessus très
sale mais ça y est j'ai cru au potentiel
de la bande dessinée et qui se réclame
est directement de tout faire et il
prenait déjà un pseudo quand même
c'était alors si noble que cela alors
oui peut-être que sa carrière de
professeur des écoles aurez vos rires
oui mais bon georges colomb christophe
c'était c'était c'était bien trouver
alors voilà zig et puce maintenant à la
sat aux gants là c'est une vraie
révolution lui c'est celui qui va
inspirer et à hergé bien sûr mais c'est
surtout vous le rappeler dans votre
livre c'est celui qui utilise le premier
des phylactères les bleus en france
enfin ce que les les bulles exister aux
états unis depuis un moment mais il y
avait une résistance en france en france
au fond on a une tradition assez
littéraire qui vient nous dire que s'il
n'ya pas du texte explicatif sous
l'image on n'est pas vraiment dans une
forme noble alors que aux états unis on
croit à la plus sud raconté par les
bulles et saint-ogan va l'adopter
immédiatement
il s'inspire d'ailleurs d'un dessinateur
américain il paraît dans la presse il
paraît très vite sous forme d'album et
zig et puce de vienne est immensément
immensément populaire surtout à cause du
pingouin alfred c'est le pingouin eux
qui devient une mascotte même joséphine
baker s'est servi du pingouin on pose
avec lui et hergé tout jeune viendra
rendre visite à saint-ogan qui regarde
ses premiers dessins et il lui offre une
planche originale est alors le titre la
planche originale c'est vraiment
savoureux c'est un cadeau puisque cette
gloire et richesse
c'était pas mal vu pour le jeune berger
qui retrouvera saint-ogan tout à la fin
de sa vie et qui donc est un un auteur
fantaisistes comme les rejets à ses
débuts il n'est pas du tout soucieux de
réalisme vous voyez ici zig et puce en
l'an 2000 faut imaginer que moi au début
de ses berges et voilà donc hergé 6-2
saint-ogan hergé petit belge né dans un
milieu pas très cultivé plus nourrie par
le cinéma muet que par les livres et qui
va évidemment ont donné à la bande
dessinée une ampleur inimaginable on
viendra et âgés mais passons d'abord aux
états unis on va respecter le
chapitrage le chapitrage de votre livre
aux états unis on y arrive avec le
yellow kid de richard felton à aux côtes
c'est à partir de 1896 le yellow kid ça
durera pas très longtemps mais ça va
marquer tout le monde et c'est vrai
quand on le regarde je trouve que c'est
d'une beauté extraordinaire à ceux d'une
beauté extraordinaire d'une lisibilité
d'une fluidité formidable alors ce qui
est amusant c'est que le yellow kid au
départ un gamin des rues de new york un
petit à petit pauvre avec sa chemise de
nuit jaune un peu improbable puisqu'il
apporte même dans la rue au départ ce
sont des grandes images très très
compliqué et c'est petit à petit code qu
on se dit ah mais je te pourrait diviser
sa en plusieurs images et puis placez le
texte non seulement sur la chemise de
nuit comme on le voit mais aussi dans
des bulles et le premier qui utilise une
bulle c'est un perroquet donc c'est très
drôle parce qu'en fait la bulle est
utilisé pour une parole mécanique pour
se moquer en fait du perroquet ou
d d d d d appareils d 10
et le brillant et puis petit à petit et
bien les personnages se mettent à parler
les autres dessinateurs de l'époque
voile et planche puis yellow kid mais
c'est génial ce truc là et en deux trois
ans tout le monde adopte le procédé est
là on a vraiment un âge d'or américain
qui va durer dix quinze ans où on est
dans les journaux du dimanche qui sont
en couleurs sont des suppléments de très
grand format et donc je crois que c'est
l'émerveillement petit là le premier sac
la couleur c'est rare à l'époque et puis
avoir une page que les enfants peuvent
aimer que les adultes peuvent aimer
c'est quelque chose qui fait vendre les
journaux et donc il rompt patrons de
presse se battent pour avoir les
meilleurs de prodigieuses artistes on va
voir winsor mccay little nemo alors lui
dessine les rêves d'un petit garçon
c'est absolument prodigieux alors winsor
mccay pour moi c'est après te faire le
deuxième génie de l'histoire de la belle
fille et c'est un artiste complet
puisqu'il va aussi être un précurseur du
dessin animé est connue puisque enfin
mal connus sont ces mêmes passages de
décence alors on n'hésite
on ne fait pas tout à fait s'il est né
dans les environs chicago ou au canada
ce qui est sûr c'est que dès son plus
jeune âge il dessine tout le temps il
fait son apprentissage dans les parcs
forains il fait des portraits de gens en
quelques instants et puis va se nourrir
de cet univers des parcs d'attractions
et aussi de l'expo universelle de
chicago qui l'impressionnent énormément
par ces constructions csu baisse de
construction féerique on va retrouver au
fond les états unis en train de naître
de se bâtir et en même temps
éternellement le rêve du petit nemo qui
est inspiré du fils de noël winsor mccay
donc il prend un petit garçon de cinq ou
six ans ce garçon immanquablement part
dans le monde du rêve et se réveille
donc à la dernière image de chaque page
on le voit se réveiller parfois de
manière un peu un peu turbulent et ça
nous permet à la fois de découvrir tous
les états unis de l'époque apple canada
mais aussi de partir sur la lune sur la
planète mars dans les choses les plus
incroyables dans des palais des glaces
où tout se transforme et de jouer là on
peut le dire vraiment avec génie sur ce
que la bande dessinée permet c'est à
dire que chez winsor mc urnes et pas
seulement dans une addition de petites
images ce qui était un peu le gâcher
christophe on a joué mais de penser
comme bagage est aussi quelque chose de
global il faut imaginer pour des enfants
de l'époque n'est ce pas abreuvés
d'image comme aujourd'hui voir ces
grandes pages voir un éléphant que je
dirige à l'autre est très grand ça
devait être une sensation extraordinaire
doc acte c'est double lecture chez
winsor mccay ce convoi d'un coup d'oeil
qui doit alors vous en jeter plein la
vue et puis après prendre son temps et
lire et relire ce petit rêve
contemporain de frey d'ailleurs ils sont
inconnus même si freud voyager aux
etats-unis ces années là on aurait bien
aimé connaître leur dialogue vous citez
gazoline allait alors qu'on connaît pas
de francs king qui paraît à partir de
1921 je crois et qui est la série qui va
avoir la plus grande longévité et qui a
une invention extraordinaire de gazoline
aller c'est que les personnages vont
vieillir en fait le personnage
principal recueille un petit orphelin
qui a été abandonnée devant sa porte et
à célibataire il adopte le gamin il a
essayé de le faire
et il va élever cet enfant qui va
grandir qui va devenir adulte qui va
devenir soldat qui aura lui même des
enfants et il ya une poésie dans cette
série qui a été redécouverte par un des
plus grands auteurs américains
d'aujourd'hui qui s'appelle chris ware
c'est lui on en reparlera peut-être que
le grand prix d'angoulême l'année
dernière et chris ware a vraiment
recueilli ces pages pour montrer leur
beauté pour les rééditer dans toute leur
splendeur à l'instauration
oublier le bon allez vous aussi laissez
derrière vous aux lecteurs du liban la
façon à flash gordon on connaît tous son
nom flash gordon bien qu'en france il
s'appelait deal est clair c'est la
grande série de science fiction à partir
de 2 du début des années 30 c'est à
l'extrême on qui la destine
flash gordon c'est parce que c'est de la
science fiction que ça un tel écho ou
parce que c'est génial parce que c'est
un dessinateur prodigieux vie plate
invention c&c autruches bizarre qui tire
ce char on est dans un monde entre le
moyen-age la préhistoire le futurisme
c'est tout à fait tout à fait
extraordinaire dans dans son imaginaire
il y a eu chez à l'extrêmement une
virtuosité graphique et le fait de
s'adresser assez largement un public
d'adultes et ça on a beaucoup de
préjugés finalement sur la bande du ciné
parce que en europe et en france
particulièrement on a vu la bande
dessinée comme un divertissement pour
les petits assez vite on s'est
spécialisée dans la bande des cyprès p
aux etats unis c'est pas du tout le cas
on a eu des situations c'est bien belle
adresse à tout le monde les ambitieuses
et voilà remis et donc on peut traiter
du sujet sérieux on peut faire de la fsf
on peut faire du polar
à l'extrême ans a travaillé aussi avec
dashiell hammett donc grand romancier de
roman noir dont il y avait là quelque
chose qui a disparu au fond après la
seconde guerre mondiale c'est éviter que
la bande dessinée dont les journaux
parlaient à tous les publics peut-être
aux 1 d'abord sur le plan visuel et aux
autres par un feuilleton qu'on suivait
et la bande dessinée n'était pas vouée
l'humour bien sûr j'avais des séries
d'humour un tréteau beaucoup de drôlerie
mais il y avait des séries plus plus
sérieuse et cette diversité faisait
finalement la richesse de la bande
dessinée dans les années 20 et 30
qui ont frappé des gens comme alain
resnais par exemple rémo forlani chris
marker bien d'autres enfants ont
découvert ces bandes dessinées dans des
adaptations françaises parfois un peu
traficoter avec des couleurs parfois un
peu dénaturée et pour qui sait rester
l'âge d'or alain resnais et grands
cinéastes
collectionnait chercher encore les
journaux de son enfance et a cherché à
retrouver ce monde magique qui avait
ouvert son imaginaire un moment clé
c'est la naissance de superman en 1938
jane siegel et joe shuster sont très
jeunes ils ont 23 24 ans il avant que
superman ces lois parmi les super héros
ils vont avoir du mal d'ailleurs
personne n'en veut personne n'en veut et
superman
carrière d'autant plus extraordinaire
qu'il ouvre la porte à tous les super
héros qui vont qui vont naître la suite
au moment de la seconde guerre mondiale
ils vont se bousculer un oui tout à fait
alors il ya évidemment cette coïncidence
tout à fait remarquable entre la montée
des périls et l'apparition des super
héros c'est à dire l'amérique se cherche
des sauveurs a été personnage qui
incarne sa puissance mais ce qui est
très étrange avec les super héros c'est
que pendant longtemps ils sont le
symbole même de la bande dessinée
américaine et qu'aujourd'hui pour les
jeunes générations ce sont des figures
de cinéma est donc là il va y avoir un
transfert si on demande à un jeune qui
est batman spider man sera ce sont des
personnages de films parce que avec le
numérique on a pu tout faire on a pu
faire exister les exploits les plus
extravagants spéciaux avec osi démarrer
mais et dans les jeux vidéo mais
évidemment à l'époque il était
absolument magique de pouvoir faire
exister l'impossible par le dessin et ça
ça nous raconte aussi quelque chose de
la bande définissez que elle est capable
avec le talent de quelques auteurs de
faire naître des monte alors que les
technologies cinématographiques à
l'époque les effets spéciaux sont plus
sont plus rudimentaires aujourd'hui la
bande dessinée explore d'autres
territoires parce que le cinéma c'est un
peu emparée de certains de ces domaines
est justement l'autre le grand génie de
du monde des super héros en bande
dessinée c'est stan lee sa stade lille
qui va en créer un nombre absolument
enfin ces industriels là on voit l'homme
araignée et bien sûr mais je la préfère
je me posais parce que moi je me
souviens très bien je lisais strange
quand j'étais quand j'étais enfant et
c'est dans strange convoyer iron man
daredevil
spider man les x men je me demande si
beaucoup de petits garçons en france on
lisait ce que je crois pas que c'était
très très populaire strange et les super
héros en bande dessinée je me demande si
ça l'était alors ça l'été aux états unis
très certainement malgré la censure 1 au
moment du mccarthysme et à une censure
assez fort puis une autorégulation c'est
à dire que les producteurs
de super-héros accepter eux mêmes un
certain nombre de limites notamment ray
hollywood évitez de partir trop loin
dans la violence dans le fantastique
dans le gore qui avaient été des
domaines très très explorer mais on a
avec stan lee avec jack kirby et
d'autres grands grands auteurs une
imagination absolument incroyable je te
dire je n'ai pas grandi avec ses bandes
dessinées l'âge de 10 ans enfin en
belgique j'ai grandi avec d'autres des
idées je les ai découvertes un peu un
peu plus tard et on reste évidemment
impressionné par leur leur liberté
graphique la manière d'utiliser la
pagerie dès que que tout est possible
dans l'histoire comme comme comme
visuellement évidemment ce sont aussi
des codes couleurs qui n'ont rien à voir
avec ce que les amateurs de tintin et
spirou en ont connues on est dans des
couleurs beaucoup plus vite beaucoup
plus franche et ans un usage de la page
beaucoup plus débordant est alors un
instant après ton nous sur peanuts
charlie brown snoopy
dessiné pendant un demi-siècle par
charles schulz un tous les matins il
s'asseyait à son bureau il faisait sa
bande son strip qui paraissant et la
centaine de journées demi-page pour le
dimanche et oblige souvent les auteurs
américains d'ailleurs avait cette
discipline du petit strip noir et blanc
aps les jours de semaine et de la demie
page encore
peanuts ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
au fond avec ses petits personnages de
lurcy simple d'avoir créé
des héros mais extrêmement attachant
extrêmement proche de nous un peu
philosophe à l'heure à leur façon se
souvient tous de phrases qu'ils ont
qu'ils ont prononcés et et il ya là
quelque chose qui montre qu'un art
minimaliste peut parler au coeur chris
ware que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
raconte qu'un jour pour la saint
valentin il avait envoyé une carte
postale à charlie brown pour qu'il se
sente pas trop seul c'est donc dire
qu'un petit personnage fait de quelques
traits pouvait éveiller des sentiments
et donner le sentiment d'être un ami et
ça ça vient de quoi bien je pense que ça
vient tout simplement la présence
quotidienne dans le journal un strip
n'est rien mes strips après streep nous
découvrons ce monde et de nous y
attachons et c'était une des beautés une
poésie qui a disparu aujourd'hui parce
que nous n'avons plus de ces séries que
nous suivons jour après jour dans les
journaux mais y en avait aussi dans les
journaux français france soir était à
une époque le plus grand journal
français de bande dessinée une série
comme 13 rue de l'espoir par exemple
était un feuilleton qu'on suivait
comment suis aujourd'hui des séries télé
alors il va y avoir une pause mais mais
d'abord hergé et tintin premier tintin
enfin il crée tintin en 1929
on en revient toujours pas de tintin
c'était quand même assez extraordinaire
les enfants d'aujourd'hui lis tintin
avec la même passion que j'ai lu tintin
que nos parents ont lu tintin est le
pays où il est le plus populaire
aujourd'hui c'est la chine s'est lâché
le feuilleton ami tchang alors hergé
cette extraordinaire bon c'est l'auteur
de bandes dessinées que je connais le
mieux d'abord j'ai eu la chance de le
connaître lui d'écrire sa biographie
mais je reste émerveillé par cette façon
qu'il a eue de s'approprier totalement
langage de la bande dessinée et on peut
vraiment dire car j'ai c'est la bande
dessinée fait tom c'est à dire qu on a
l'impression que tout son talent de
narrateur de metteur en scène deux
dessinateurs d'acteurs et l'a mis dans
la bande dessinée et vous prenez
l'histoire comme le lotus bleu c'est un
référent historique très loin de nous on
peut encore la lyre et y croire alors
que les événements sont très atteinte à
au tibet je vous défie de la raconter un
enfant sans verser là mme à la fin il ya
là quelque chose qui à la drôlerie les
mots du capitaine haddock les pitreries
des dupont le champ de la castafiore
mais par delà la drôlerie ski l'univers
qu'il ya une poésie une profondeur il a
comme chaplin ou à disney dans un autre
genre cette capacité à être jamais date
et anne un programme adapté peut-être
que bien acquis à ça aujourd'hui dans le
monde du dessin animé voilà quelques
artistes ont à la fois la capacité à
parler aux plus jeunes comme aux plus
âgés 1 michel serres était un passionné
de tintin mais aussi à être passés de
génération en génération depuis 1929
jusqu'à 2020 de presque un siècle cc
c'est assez ludique il ya très peu
d'offres bien sûr les chapines vous avez
raison on revoit les grands films de
chaplin avec la même émotion ou n'oublie
que c'est en noir et blanc on oublie que
c'est
et on entre dans l'histoire et chergé
qui était un admirateur de chaplin et de
buster keaton d'harold lloyd et des
autres il ya cette capacité qui je le
compare quelquefois hitchcock parce
qu'il ya une chose qu'il aurait commune
c'est le mélange du suspense et de
l'humour c'est très difficile de mélange
décès dû avoir un récit d'aventurés
trépidantes et en même temps les vrais
gag r je hergé le fait dans tous ses
albums et hitchcock par exemple dans la
mort aux trousses vous êtes sans arrêt
entre entre l'angoissé tu es et les et
le rire on fait une pause benoît peeters
on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
nous continuons d'égrainer les 50
moments clés de l'histoire de la bande
dessinée avec benoît peeters
on vient de passer hergé
pourquoi pas alix le héros de jacques
martin alix c'est très beau et très bien
dessiné c'est de la bande dessinée
classique ç dû être moderne aussi à une
époque c'est alors il faut imaginer que
l'auteur jacques martin pas confondre
avec d'autres jacques martin c'était un
français qui est venu s'installer en
belgique parce que la bande dessinée
était extraordinairement vivante et donc
quand on parle de bd belge quelquefois
on oublie que c'était parce que
bruxelles et charleroi étaient devenus
des pôles essentiels pour la bande
dessinée jacques martin ad'ailleurs été
longtemps l'un des assistants des rejets
d'un juin des studios hergé mais ce
qu'il développe dans ces histoires il le
développe sur un mode plus sérieux du
réaliste avec une documentation
considérable donc annick sa jeune
gaulois de l'époque de jules césar qui
est liée aux romains et qui va vivre des
aventures plus extraordinaires les unes
que les autres et tout précisément dater
et documenté et vous voyez en même temps
que dans les plus belles aventures de
ces documentation n'étouffe pas le génie
graphique de jacques martin qui est
aussi un génie de metteur en scène on
parle souvent des perspectives la
précision des décors mais regardez
comment sire que d'image en image comme
tout ça est fluide lisible avec une
unité il ya vraiment une grande grande
beauté et je pense que beaucoup de
jeunes ont découvert l'antiquité
finalement bon bah après on a eu le
versant comique de l'antiquité avec
astérix mais alix et son versant sérieux
et sûrement que quelques vocations
d'historiens et d'archéologues son nez
en lisant cette très belle ça vous fait
remarquer dans votre livre également que
dans la bd belge il n'ya pas d'héroïne
n'y a pas de femmes elles n'ont
quasiment aucune place c'est le cas
d'ailleurs fait l x chez alix même il ya
une on a toujours vu une espèce de
d'homosexualité l'attend chez alix et
enak wind ac voilà ils sont toujours
torse nu dans bon antiquités l'antiquité
dans
participé sans succès l'absence des
femmes est criante oui alors cette
absence de femmes il faut pas
re prêter comme de la misogynie de la
part des dessinateurs c'est plutôt la
censure ou
l'autocensure qui pesait sur eux puisque
les mouvements catholiques ont beaucoup
fait pour le développement de la bande
dessinée tintin à lui-même est né dans
les journaux catholiques et les journaux
comme spirou et tintin dans la précaires
avaient des abonnements multiples dans
les collèges or dit qu'il y avait une
représentation féminine un peu
différente de bianca castafiore dont ils
ont possiblement
sexy si minimalement que ce soit il y
avait des menaces de désabonnement et
donc les auteurs se sont habitués
jusqu'au milieu des années soixante à
construire des histoires avec des
garçons pour des magazines qui était
essentiellement lui par des garçons et
sahin mis longtemps à évoluer évidemment
des auteurs comme jacques martin hergé
ou edgar jacob qui a fait blake et
mortimer a brusquement changé d'univers
vous diront on n'allait pas avoir tout
d'un coup alix se marier au tintin avoir
une petite amie l'univers était déjà mis
en place et donc ça peut donner pour des
lectrices et des lecteurs d'aujourd'hui
un sentiment un peu bizarre on vit dans
une société totalement différente très
mixte pour n'imagine même pas ce que ça
pourrait être qu'un univers peuplé de
garçons des grandes séries qui ont
aujourd'hui tant d'adeptes avait raison
des personnages féminins formidable et
donc c'est peut-être une faiblesse de la
bd franco-belge de cette époque
faiblesse que n'a pas eue la bande
dessinée américaine grande et eni la
bande dessinée japonaise grande figure
de la bande dessinée belge et franquin
qui va reprendre le personnage de spirou
et créé le personnage de gaston lagaffe
qui va être une immense star de la bande
dessinée des années 60 et 70 là on est
plutôt du côté de spirou et fantasio
qu'est-ce qui fait le génie de franquin
pour vour à la fois en tant que
dessinateur et en tant que scénariste
alors c'est un magnifique magnifique
dessinateur 1 qui a l'air d'être un
caricaturiste dessinateurs d'humour et
emmène dans son dessin extrêmement
nourris d'observation les attitudes sont
très très juste c'est un patron du monde
moderne vous savez la belgique a connu
en 1958 l'exposition universelle et on a
l'impression en lisant les albums de
spirou et même les premiers gaston on a
l'impression d'être dans ce monde là
c'est à dire un peu américanisé avec un
goût des gadgets la miniaturisation ici
dans cette dans cette page il se passe
quelque chose de formidable c'est que le
marsupilami création invention très
joyeuse de franquin a avalé un tout
petit transistor et ce transistor se
dérègle et émet toutes sortes de bruits
et donc on a là une des preuves parmi
d'autres du génie de franck avec du
génie de la bande dessinée c'est la
capacité à restituer le son puisque tout
d'un coup cette histoire est
complètement parasité par le transistor
qui change de gènes sans arrêt et qui
d'une certaine façon empêche les
personnages de parler d'ailleurs les
derniers mots de cette page c'est un peu
de silence donc formidable de se dire
que dans un bar muet on arrive à donner
le sentiment du bruit on l'aura dans les
bijoux de la castafiore berger avec les
gammes avec le champ de la castafiore
qui fait qu'il fait trembler les murs de
la bande dessinée
n'a rien à envier au cinéma ni à la
radio ni à la télé elle est capable de
tout traduire avec son langage à elle
est un auteur comme comme franquin en
plus un car d'une sorte de joie qui
contraste avec le personnage de franquin
qui était assez dépressive ce temps
plein dans mais vous savez bien mal
d'humoristes 1 qui sont hyper elle est
dépressif cacher passons à la france et
au magazine pilote qui né en 1959 où va
paraître astérix le gaulois
pilote opère une véritable révolution
dans les années 60 70
c'est là où tout à coup on a
l'impression que la bande dessinée va
mourir et ce qui est fascinant quand on
voit cette image autour de rené goscinny
qui on devient le rédacteur en chef qui
est quand même l'auteur à la fois
d'astérix de lucky luke et predica et du
petit nicolas
212 d'où mon papa donc un fantastique
auteurs de bande dessinée mais aussi qui
va se révéler un patron de presse
extraordinaire et qui va rassembler
autour de lui une cohorte de génie qui
est quand même c'est impressionnant mais
ressent tout cela il ya eu bretécher
fred druyer giraud tous sont tous ont
leur taux de rené de choses va se passer
tout ce qui va faire bouger la bande
dessinée en france puis qui va peut-être
d'ailleurs déplacé le pôle principal de
de bruxelles à paris alors il faut dire
que goscinny allie deux talents qui vont
très rarement de pair c'est un très
grand auteur un très grand scénariste et
en même temps c'est un éditeur d'une
générosité extraordinaire donc y
développe sa propre oeuvre avec le
succès qu'on s'est assez vite des 65
astérix est extraordinaire donc il
pourrait tout à fait laisser tomber le
journal pilote non il s'occupe de ce
journal et chaque année il veut faire
découvrir au public est imposé au public
un nouvel auteur alors ce sera fred avec
fils aimant ce sera côte libre avec la
rubrique à brac ce sera claire bretécher
la première femme vraiment très célèbre
dans le monde de la bande dessinée ça
sera mézières qui nous a quittés
récemment meyer et christain qu'ils font
valérian des jean giraud gerbe 12 a pas
quittés il était dans cette émission y'a
pas longtemps ben oui mais depuis deux
ans a quitté abassis
récemment et et et jean giraud l'auteur
de blueberry avec charlier qui deviendra
moebius in qui est vraiment alors une de
ses figures extraordinaire puisqu'il il
représente d'un côté encore le
classicisme dans sa perfection avec les
aventures de blueberry un magnifique
western en bande c et d'un autre côté
l'aspiration à au monde de l'après 68 au
new age à la science fiction la plus
débridée au dessin en liberté donc on a
vraiment avec pilote un journal qui va
faire passer d'abord défini de l'enfance
à l'adolescence et de l'adolescence à
l'âge adulte et donc c'est fondamental
et en même temps le rôle de goscinny
avec astérix goscinny et uderzo bien sûr
c'est aussi de permettre un public très
très large de se dire ben oui se passe
quelque chose remporter si on aura une
couverture de l'express en 68 qui ont
consacré au phénomène assez x est donc
là les gens qui regardaient la bd comme
ça d'un petit peu loin à ce qu'il se
passe quand même quelque chose qui ne
défend pas que commercial qui nous parle
du monde qui en ayant l'air de parler
des gaulois nous parle aussi de
l'univers qui s'élance et frappe en chez
gotlib d'ailleurs qui vous consacrez une
double page la rubrique à brac de gotlib
bas ce qui m'a toujours frappé dans les
desseins des hoplites pour moi c'est
plus grands dessinateurs du mouvement
les personnages de gotlib sont
totalement en mouvement en permanence
pas forcément là où c'est le plus
frappant à part dans la case en bas à
gauche mais l'effet de les museler les
jeunes physionomie et puis alors ok c
cnet le début de l'auto représentation
en bande et gottlieb finalement
hésiteront propre zéro il a peint
pourvoi il apparaît constamment dans ces
bandes est fier fut un auteur qui va
avoir une période baekeland wayang il
montre goscinny bien sûr le ferai dit
les biens se regroupe bien sûr mais le
héros commence à être éclipsés par
l'auteur et ce qui est à la fois
remarquable et un peu triste chez go
type qui est aussi un personnage sombre
qui a eu une jeunesse très très sombres
marquées par la guerre c'est que sa
période de grande créativité c'est une
quinzaine d'années et qu'après il
dirigera fluide glacial mais il ne
décidera plus donc on a un moment de
flamboiement et il faut dire que juste
avant et juste après 68 on a dans la
bande dessinée française quelque chose
qui se passe on est vraiment géré au
coeur de la culture jeune quoi rock et
bande dessinée ça sera incarné par métal
hurlant c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
qui porte aujourd'hui la bande dessinée
très vivante mais n'était plus aussi
central et l'a1 un moment on a eu
l'impression que c'était là que ça se
passe et moi j'ai eu la chance d'entrer
un peu dans ce monde à ce moment là où
on avait l'impression qu'il ya des
causes il ya aussi des hebdomadaires
très puissants qui les hebdomadaires et
mensuels elias al masri lienne l'adulte
avec le côté provocateur pour les
contenus politiques et que les coûts
c'est le dessin mais oui le dessin
maradan cela s'arrête là que d'auto
souvient aujourd'hui à travers le film
de roger vadim interprétée par jane
fonda mais c'est d'abord une bande
dessinée baba et là c'est la bande
dessinée érotique oui alors dans les
années 60 donc sous forme de livre
jean-claude nospelt publie barbares l
api publiera les albums de l'italien
crepax valentina et c'est un pion des
albums un roi qui vont secouer grande
route imprégner les imaginaire érotique
de de pas mal d'adolescents et d'adultes
même si ces lits sont pas supposés être
être vendu aux enfants la bande dessinée
devient adulte et elle devient adulte
aussi par ses transgressions et ses
audaces et puis il faut reconnaître
que l'érotisme en bande dessinée de la
plupart du temps et quand même assez
raffiné puisqu'il est transcendé par le
dessin par la pornographie on est
vraiment dans le rouge avec milo manara
dans les années 80 il déclic ou chez
d'une grande pornographie dans ces
magnifiques parce que ça reste un débat
là et c'est extrêmement différent de la
représentation naturaliste un mot sur
crabe qu'on connaît pour pour le dessin
animé fritz the cat mais qui est d'abord
un auteur de bande dessinée on voit la
crabe lui c'est une vraie révolution à
l'époque il incarne quasiment là la
contre-culture américaine ça vient tout
seul tout à fait il y avait eu avant la
revue made il avait été très importante
et puis dans les années juste après 68 à
san francisco notamment on va avoir
toute cette presse un organe au début
quand même le vent lui même dans la rue
son petit journal et puis il est
rapidement imité il influence énormément
de gens pas seulement par les contenus
sexuels mais par la manière très
personnelle de parler de se mettre en
scène de raconter ses préoccupations ses
indignations de vivre avec la bande
dessinée au fonds de se dire que un
écrivain peut s'exprimer par la
littérature est qu un auteur de bande
dessinée peut s'exprimer pleinement et à
la bd alors je crois qu'il ya pas un
auteur de bande dessinée aux états unis
qui ne reconnaissent pas sa dette envers
crom dont on conçoit dans ce style là ou
pas tout le monde dit ça a été un
libérateur comme goscinny l'arrêter il
vit en france d'ailleurs crumble il
vient en france du tueur lien est alors
bretécher la première femme on était
chez elle aussi c'est un génie et c'est
doublement en face et sa réelle génie
pour moi c'est qu'elle fait avec les
frustrés en 1973 elle elle capte une
génération la sienne mais elle va
refaire le coup avec la génération
suivante dans agrippine et ça c'est très
très rare d'être arrivé à ce poids
dépeindre deux générations c'est très
fort vous avez raison alors elle avait
un statut un peu privilégié parce
qu'elle était la femme la plus connue de
la mauricie est très belle et
remarquablement bel/fra pendant qu'on la
voit dans la photo de pilotes accorder
tous les autres on se dit devaient tous
être un peu amoureux d'elle côté
extraordinaire très talentueuse très
talentueuse comme observatrice roland
barthes avait dit que c'était la
meilleure sociologue française
remarquables comme caricaturiste
vraiment elle l a beaucoup beaucoup de
talent mais on oublie quelquefois qu'il
y avait d'autres femmes dessinatrice à
cette époque comme nicole claveloux
comme chantal montellier comme florence
cestac enfin annie goetzinger qui n'ont
pas eu toute la lumière qu'elle méritait
d'un voyage je dois dire que moi quand
j'ai débuté comme jeune scénariste de
bande dessinée j'étais quand même frappé
désagréablement par le côté un peu macho
et les lieux et une des améliorations
qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est qu'on voit
beaucoup de dessinatrice on voit
beaucoup plus de lectrices on voit
beaucoup plus d'héroïne intéressante et
je dois dire que cette féminisation de
la bande dessinée c'est vraiment un des
grands grands acquis franchement c'était
un monde de mecs et parfois c'était un
peu pesant et c'était pesant pour les
pour les dessinatrices dans certaines
zones n'ont pas été accueillis comme
elles auraient dû l'être maintenant si
on regarde hugo pratt corto maltese là
il ya des personnages féminins assez
extraordinaire tout à fait là on est
avec avec hugo pratt pour moi lalita l
album décidé tout à coup la arrive à la
hauteur de la littérature c'est pour moi
la première fois je ne sais pas si c'est
la première fois mais en tout cas ça a
été très marquant on emploie un propos
de la ballade de la mer salée la
première histoire avec corto maltese
l'expression de romans en bande dessinée
aujourd'hui on va parler de roman
graphique mais à l'époque on parlait de
romande on essaie il est vrai qu'il ya
une ampleur dans ce récit dans la
ballade de la mer salée ça commence par
un premier texte qui dit je suis de
l'océan et je suis le plus grand on me
dit pacifique mais il n'est pas sûr que
je le souhaite c'est l'océan pacifique
lui même qui parle et on est dans le
monde de joseph conrad dans le monde
moby dick des grands romans de la mer de
stevenson toutes ses auteurs qu'admirer
prat il est nourri en même temps d'un
très grand dessinateur américain qui est
milton caniff et dont il a grandi en
italie il a vécu en argentine donc il
arrivé en ethiopie en abyssinie le voilà
alors il accompagne son père avec un
ensemble de culture avec une culture
littéraire qui fait qu'ils des amis de
umberto eco il a rencontré borgès envoyé
ils portent quelque chose et il va
certainement donner des idées à un
certain nombre de gens notamment aux
éditions casterman qui crée pour lui le
magazine à suivre et ce magazine va
développer des histoires avec forest
avec tardi avec didier comès avec
beaucoup d'autres et va développer
souvent en noir et blanc ces récits de
grande ampleur parmi ces grands récits
il y aura par exemple le transperceneige
de loeb et rochette qui était plus tard
adapté au cinéma mais qui était déjà une
histoire extraordinaire dans sa version
amendée qui est aussi une série sur
d'être fixé actuellement tafer a envoyé
la bande décide et peut vivre sous
d'autres formes mais la bande dessinée
peut nourrir l'imaginaire des autres
voire allons sur les sur les mangas et
particulier sur daru taux de de kashi
moto les mangas alors pendant très
longtemps mois de laissant j'ignorais
qu'il y avait une bande dessinée
japonaise a dit c'est dans les années 80
que apparaîtront dès des ces gens là
avec des oeuvres totalement radicalement
différente de celle que nous
connaissions qu'est ce que va nous
apporter le manga alors ce qu'il faut
dire d'abord c'est que le développement
du manga et ya un homme qui est le rg ou
le disney japonais qui était en tout cas
tezuka dans l'après-guerre a créé
énormément de personnages astro boy va
créer à la fois des bandes dessinée et
du dessin animé il va créer une
émulation extraordinaire il va y avait
l'idée pour les mangas naruto et autres
d'avoir des feuilletons de très très
grande ampleur est allé pendant des
années dans des journaux très bon marché
et donc on va finaliser un public qui ne
se contente pas de lire une histoire
mais d'accompagner une saga pendant très
très longtemps et aujourd'hui que la
france est devenue le deuxième pays du
manga
le manga cette année enfin l'année 2021
voilà ça c'est pour les filles l'homme
sans talent c'est beaucoup plus
ambitieux que ceux de la bande dessinée
docteur yao japon des bandes dessinées
pour tous et des bandes dessinées
documentaires il ya des bandes dessinées
pour le troisième âge il ya des bandes
dessinées érotiques spécialisé bonne dj
et tout ce que vous voulez et à ses
côtés pendant le manga il est lavé mais
vraiment pour tout le monde y fait
partie de la vie quotidienne quand on
regarde akira par exemple de l or
katsuhiro otomo voilà on se voit que
c'est c'est en termes de dessin est
assez extraordinaire ah oui ça reste il
souhaiterait la spoliation du manga que
l'image des dessins animés japonais
qu'on voyait l'après-midi dans les
émissions dorothée mais n'ont cédé très
très grand dans le east un très très
grand narrateur vit la connaît c'est la
chance de connaître depuis longtemps eu
otomo même si on ne partage pas la même
langue et c'est quelqu'un qui a
exactement les mêmes préoccupations que
les auteurs de bande dessinée européenne
raconter une histoire la mettre en scène
ménager des temps forts et puis un
dessin est extrêmement fouillée et
puissant avec double page mais il ya
quelque chose qui est quand même très
fort avec le manga est très fort pour
pour les enfants d'aujourd'hui c'est
quand même d'avoir créé une lecture a
dit yves nationale on voit les gamins
des gamines entrer dans les librairies
demander quand va sortir le tome 13 ou
le tome 18 et la tendre avec force et
c'est un rôle pour la lecture comparable
à celui d'harry potter dans le roman
c'est à dire non pas de la lecture
obligée ou imposer mais la lecture
passion et je suis toujours persuadé que
ceux qui démarrent avec la lecture
patients à 10 ans 12 ans 14 ans
resteront toute leur vie des gens qui
aiment le livre et la lecture et qui se
diversifieront vous avez parlé de maus
tout à l'heure en début d'émission le
seul premier roman graphique 1
l'oeuvre d'art spiegelman on en voit ici
une planche c'est en 1981 il va y avoir
ensuite persepolis de marjane satrapi en
2007 autres romans graphiques lui aussi
en noir et blanc d'ailleurs alors je
rigole ban a ouvert un territoire aux
états unis il a fait entrer le graphic
novel comme on disait dans les
librairies et les bibliothèques qui n'en
voulait pas on a vu que ça restait
fragile et il donne l'idée qu'avec un
dessin simple on peut raconter une
histoire forte de manière universelle et
donc marjane satrapi qui au début e et
dessinateur dessinatrice peut-être
encore un petit peu rudimentaire dans
son style à une telle force narrative en
elle qu'elle va raconter une histoire
qui touche tout le monde et je dis
souvent si marjane satrapi avait frappé
à la porte d'un producteur on dire je
voudrais faire un dessin animé qui
raconte ma jeunesse d'enfants iranienne
exilée on lui aurait ri au nez on leur
dit qu'ils ça va intéresser mais elle a
dessiné cette histoire page après page
le public est venu peu à peu et un jour
tout naturellement elle a pu participer
à l'adaptation en bande dessinée en
dessin animé de son histoire et ça c'est
la force de la bd c'est aussi qu' on
peut la faire chez soi on peut la faire
sans un matériel coûteux on peut la
faire sans un financement incroyable et
ça c'est ce qui vous voulez monter une
pièce de théâtre faire un film monter un
opéra même un groupe musical c'est pas
simple la bande dessinée avec du talent
et de la patience quand même beaucoup de
patience pour d'assiduité et d'énergie
comme je le vois avec mon ami françois
skytone depuis si longtemps eh bien on
peut mener à bien le monde dont on rêve
que ce soit un monde personnel et
réaliste un nom du mot ristic ou un
monde fantastique et ça c'est quand même
une force de la bande dessinée dans la
bande dessinée d'aujourd'hui vous vous
revenez sur titeuf qui est un véritable
phénomène de libériens le hero 2 est bon
alors là ça touche les petits enfants
mais mais ça les passionne titeuf c'est
une syrie libre et sans tabous qui a
parlé aux enfants leur leur langage qui
a peut-être même créé un langage que les
enfants ont repris par la suite c'était
une façon de parler comme il le dit du
du zizi sexuel mais d'en parler sur un
mode
souvent saugrenus et drôle puisque c'est
aussi l'ignorance de l'enfant où ces
fausses connaissances qui sont mises en
scène donc c'est une série très moderne
très contemporaine ya une chose qui
m'agace un peu en bande dessinée
aujourd'hui c'est la manie de reprendre
les héros d'hier ou d'avant-hier et avec
titoff dans on a fait un héros
pleinement d'aujourd'hui et ça je crois
que c'est très important c'est le cas de
la série aussi mortelle adele qui
connaît un immense succès auprès des
enfants c'est des séries d'aujourd'hui
par des créateurs qui sont de leur temps
comme hergé jacobs seront qu'un était de
leur temps on l'a aussi séché joann sfar
avec le chat du rabbin alors qu'il se
passe dans le passé mais qui est
totalement d'aujourd'hui également un
jeune star d'abord c'est à un auteur
tout terrain avril et le multi multi
doué c'est vrai que le chat du rabbin et
peut-être sa série la plus tenue la plus
la plus forte la plaie la plus
passionnant une très très jolie idée que
finalement ce chat en sait plus que le
rabbin met en difficulté tout le bon de
faire revivre aux 6,7 cette algérie b
sur un mode tendres non c'est un auteur
très talentueux qui est en même temps
scénariste dessinateur qui a de
multiples collaborations c'est un peu un
gossip ni d'aujourd'hui il ya les cultes
et de pénélope bagieu alors pénélope
bagieu et une de celles qui incarnent la
féminisation de la bande dessinée et les
parties d'un blog comme beaucoup
d'auteurs d'aujourd'hui un artiste un
blog plutôt plutôt autobiographique et
puis petit à petit il s'est ouverte à
d'autres sujets d'autres choses et
notamment à travers les culottes et des
portraits de femmes
exceptionnelles des portraits de femmes
libres connus ou inconnus de même que
cathay l'évoquait ont développé dans
l'histoire de kiki de montparnasse ou de
joséphine baker ont je crois qu'on a
cette revalorisation des héroïnes il
était en bd parce que quand même on fait
la liste de tous les to les lucky luke
les superman et les autres et on se dit
bon ça manquait un peu de femmes donc
heureusement qu'on a quelques culotté il
ya riad sattouf aussi qui est assez
extraordinaire il ya bien sûr mais on
pourrait dire aussi avec le journal
avec les cahiers d'estaires voilà donc
que eux dans
dans la raab du futur c'est une bande
dessinée autobiographique c'est son
enfance
d'enfants entre deux entre deux cultures
etc raconté avec beaucoup d'humour et
surtout énormément de sensibilité je
crois que ça peut ça peut parler à
beaucoup de gens c'est un grand
narrateur parce que il faut pas oublier
que quand on pense bande dessinée
souvent on va penser d'abord virtuosité
graphique et puis ce qui fait qu'on
tient à une histoire et qu on est fidèle
à une série c'est la qualité du récit et
l'atelier vraiment remarquable cette
mise en page très particulier oui cet
usage très libre parce que la bande
dessinée s'est un peu libéré d'une
certaine rigidité des gaz de la forme de
la page on a aujourd'hui tous les styles
graphiques mais aussi toutes les
manières d'occuper n'a pas de couleur
noir et blanc bichromie travail plus
picturale avec avec d'autres plus
minimaliste chez certains tout est
possible et ça c'est vraiment une joie
parce que j'ai vu au fil des ans des
décennies l'amendé c'est s'ouvrir
autrefois on disait attention si vous
avez réussi a pas de bulle c'est pas de
la bd par exemple si on a vu des tas de
séries qui n'ont pas de bulle et soit
qu'ils sont muettes soit qui utilisent
le tec hainaut assure catherine meurisse
par exemple voilà de la bd qu'on
n'aurait jamais imaginé jamais vu il ya
30 ans voilà donc de la bande dessinée
politique par une autre issue qui est
entré tout récemment l'académie des
beaux-arts qui était en même temps
dessinatrice de presse à charlie hebdo
donc avec eux la tragédie qui a essayé
de 200 guérir et qui est nourrie
d'histoire de l'art nourri de
littérature et qui vient nous dire au
fond que pour les auteurs les autres is
lectrices les lecteurs d'aujourd'hui
bandes dessinées romans cinéma
télévision ça n'a pas vraiment
d'importance ce qui compte c'est qu'on
soit capable de nous faire entrer dans
un monde talentueusement et librement et
pas qu'on se dise je suis lecteur
exclusive de bd ou de manga ou de comics
ou moi je méprise la bd non je pense qu
on est capable de passer d'une forme à
l'autre et c'est peut-être ça que nous
dit joliment le mot de roman graphique
c'est que il ya le plaisir visuel le
graphisme et il ya la joie du roman avec
des livres parfois d'une grande ampleur
est une grande d'une grande profondeur
ça s'intitule trois minutes pour
comprendre 50 moments clés de l'histoire
de la bande dessinée c'est paru à la
courrier du livre et c'est signé benoît
peeters merci benoît peeters de nous
l'avoir
résumé pour un récit du on n'a pas parlé
de tout et heureusement sinon il reste
des choses à améliorer il en reste
beaucoup à découvrir merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
non